when was the last time you played
destiny 2
maybe you've never played maybe you play
every day or maybe
like me you used to play but haven't
gone back to it in a while
well firstly if you haven't played
before you should definitely try it for
yourself because you can do that
completely for free
once you've tried it come back again and
i'll tell you more but for everyone
else we're going to take a look at the
new expansion destiny 2 beyond light
[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
earlier this month bungie reached out to
me as a former destiny player and asked
if i'd like to come back and see the way
the next gen consoles and new beyond
like dlc
has evolved destiny too and i gotta say
i'm impressed
so much so that i've teamed up with
bungie to break down a handful of things
you should know and because this is a
sponsored video there's a link in the
description should you want to see it
for yourself
that includes 25 off on the newest
content and other dlcs
running until january the 5th destiny 2
is known for its space drama chronicling
our adventures planet hopping
fighting to protect humanity under the
watchful eye
of the traveller a celestial being that
looks like a giant golf ball
every game needs something weird okay
the shooting mechanics are some of the
best i've ever played and only call of
duty
can compare to how this feels as a
first-person shooter
and the looting element and searching
for weapons and upgrades are as
satisfying as they were six years ago
if you've spent time away or are new to
destiny the introduction to the game and
the mechanics have been completely
updated
this free content for all which is
automatically started once the game
opens for new players
but i also think it's worth playing even
if you are a returning player
it can be found at the tower at the
quest archive terminal
along with lots of your former missions
see this like a content refresher
the mission structure is a retelling of
the opening moments of the original
destiny game
in the cosmodrome on earth this is a
much more condensed and easy to
understand
narrative a guardian rises simplifies
the law without adding too much extra
baggage for new players
this version of the story revolves
around shaw han who is attempting to
find his crew and get back to the tower
before disaster strikes it only takes a
few hours to complete and
explains how weapon types work lost
sectors patrols
it teaches all the basic elements that
make up the experience of destiny 2.
so if you've had a break definitely try
there first
destiny 2 beyond light adds a new
location to the game
europa europa the smallest of four moons
circling jupiter and if you look closely
enough you may spot jupiter in the sky
okay it's a little closer than i
expected europa is a frozen land
seemingly untouched for generations but
actually there's more going on here than
meets the eye
and an evil kell named eremus is
harnessing the power of darkness
in the hopes of making the fallen great
again in terms of law the big golf ball
used to look after the fallen but the
traveller left them in the past
and the fallen aren't too happy about
that in the past we've had to level up
to be able to play these expansions but
not this time around so if you're
worried about jumping back in after all
this time don't worry
all your characters will automatically
be upgraded to power level 1050
allowing you to get straight into the
new stuff instead of grinding levels to
play what you paid for
so fill your boots during the story we
will harness power of darkness
the sworn enemy of light in order to be
strong enough to take down eremus
and this signals the first new element
in destiny since
2014 six whole years we've had solar
void and dark ways to control our light
but now we can harness stasis a kind of
dark ice subclass
with some pretty impressive abilities my
hunter throws down a pickaxe which
obliterates everything
nearby in a frozen tornado kind of
effect and the knife throwing ability is
replaced with a projectile that can
deflect from walls it's like a batarang
made of ice
and remember the typical grenades well
now they're a wall of ice
i'm a hunter main by the way the warlock
rocks the shade binder which utilizes a
spear-like projectile
and the titan is a behemoth with a
ground pound of devastation
beyond light marks the start of a new
trilogy in the destiny saga
all about that darkness and in order to
understand this
look who has returned the stranger
and here comes our guardian right on
time
back in 2014 this mysterious exo helped
us in the campaign
but then vanished from existence leaving
us with the greatest excuse to not talk
to someone ever
who are you why have you been watching
us
i don't even have time to explain why i
don't have time to explain
well now she's back and she better start
explaining things
i owe you an explanation for all this
over the course of the campaign we'll
unlock our new ability
and learn to use it to its fullest
against all of eremus's minions
the new subclass is going to change how
everything feels in game
in pve this will be another tactical
option but it's the pvp area which will
be most
impacted as for the last six years we've
come accustomed to the three elements on
offer
and now to throw a new one in makes for
some interesting changes in battle
as the community finds the best meta
[Music]
i'm sure you've noticed the visual
update to destiny 2 on console
i'm playing on the ps5 but it also works
on other next-gen hardware
destiny 2 is now available in 4k 60
frames per second
this video is only 1080p so you'll have
to multiply the visuals by 4 to get a
real value here
but look how beautiful it is but that's
not the thing i really want to shout
about here
it's actually a setting in the menu the
fov slider the field of view
can finally be changed on console here
let me show you why this is a big deal
the typical default field of view is
usually stuck at around 75 degrees in
first person shooters
this gives us a blend of accuracy in
gunfights and enough peripheral vision
around the sides
to spot other threats any smaller than
this and people can get
motion sick and any wider than this
hitting shots becomes particularly
hard at range so 75 degrees became the
best
middle ground destiny 2 allows us to
change this on the fly
which means if you have a preference in
other games it can now be transferred
over
and fyi i much prefer 90 a heck of a lot
more visual space
without too much of a drop in accuracy
for the ultra competitive
destiny 2 now supports 120 frames per
second
in pvp matches the crucible the place
where you take on other guardians
is where your reactions and accuracy are
most needed
so 120 frames of smoothness gives you a
significant advantage over players stuck
on 30 frames per second this is usually
one of the key reasons why players
migrate to pc
to control frame rate and field of view
and overall be in charge of how their
game
looks and you guess what i'm gonna say
next all those options are now here
on next gen consoles we can now clean up
the image
however we want it to look and finally
for next generation updates
the boot up times the loading speed is
now mind-blowing
the solid-state drives offer near
instant loading into and out of
encounters
and the same goes for character updates
of course we've still got to fly to our
destinations that will always take time
in an online game
but for context i used to watch players
speed running raids
back in the day and one of those people
was tfu and i always remember him saying
the hardest thing in speedrunning was
switching
your character's abilities around while
you waited for them to update
on ps5 and xbox series x this issue
is no more so there we have it a bunch
of cool things in the latest version of
destiny 2
beyond light from technical improvements
on console to a brand new adventure
which will make up a new trilogy in
years to come
now looks like a good time to try
destiny 2 completely free
and if you like the core loop of
shooting and looting you may want to try
the expansion beyond light
there is far more to look at and the
more i play destiny the more i want to
play destiny
so if you'd like me to cover this in
future just let me know you're in charge
of the future of this channel
i'm adam from playstation grenade thanks
to bungie for inviting me back to the
world of destiny 2 and for sponsoring
this video
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you